hi I'm amber and I'm a programmer I work
for a small start-up called student
Katya and today is a day in my life I'm
half way to work and let's keep going
[Music]
so I walked to work everyday uh well
unless it's raining because it takes
about 40 minutes and it's free and this
is my favorite part of my walk I have
this canal and there's normally a whole
bunch of ducks here but today there's no
ducks maybe they're camera shy actually
today I have super legs I've been
fiddling with this video so I'm gonna
keep moving this is my colleague
speaking Swedish gotta raise the desk so
I can stand its ergonomic oh oh I just
got to work and I'm a little sweaty from
working as always I'm gonna go get some
cheese and crackers for breakfast and
coffee and then I'm going to check slack
and do some code reviews like luck and
that means it's time for our stand-up
I'll take photo or two to show you what
that looks like we're gonna chat with
our polish colleagues who work on the
app and also our most senior developers
who happens to be a contractor who works
on everything
okay so is 1007 we just did standup
we were missing almost everyone so it
was very short stand-up I've been at
work for about an hour
currently what I'm doing is working on a
bug affecting the salaries of our
students
we're running several a bee tests and if
it turns out that this bug has been
there all the time then we've just sort
of wasted a bunch of money giving people
extra money and if it's only been two
weeks which is when a major refactor
happened to this code which fingers
crossed it's only been two weeks and
then we can just throw that data this is
very typical I go on slack in the
morning and one of our sports staff has
reported a bug or some problem that is
actually critical to fix now like this
one is specifically potentially costing
us money right now so I'm gonna work on
this until it's fixed and then I'll do
code reviews test suite takes like 12
minutes to run so now it's 1112 I'm on
Coffee number two and I squash that bug
so that's good thankfully it was only
two weeks worth of data that has been
unusable for us so the other couple of
months that it's been running it's good
to go
I did code reviews I approved some code
and I rejected some code because it
didn't work and now I'm going to get
back to the thing that I knew I was
coming when I came in this morning and
that is a big refactor currently in our
system users can have one school and we
want them to be able to work with
multiple schools so that's what I'm
gonna get back to working on now okay so
midday check-in
it's about 12:15 and I need to go get
some lunch because we have an all-hands
meeting at 1:00 every Monday and it's
Monday I typically like to eat lunch
around that time
if I don't go early and get lunch then I
had to wait sometimes still 2 o'clock
and that super late don't want to do it
today has been a pretty good day so far
it's actually been pretty standard I've
dealt with a few bugs that were sitting
in slack when I came in and I have
worked on some features I'm almost ready
with this big refactor of users can have
multiple schools that's taken me a
couple days actually I was working on
that last week all Friday but it's
almost ready to go
I did get some feedback on the bug I
fixed this morning and my code was also
rejected so I need to work on that some
more too but I'm not worried about it
because the business logic that is
handled by that particular piece of code
basically like no more bookings are
going to be made this morning that are
gonna fall into that box so I'm not
worried about doing that right away
because I'm sure I can do it this
afternoon
and then it will all work out before
tomorrow morning's a new set so I'm
gonna head over to the grocery store
they have a cafeteria type situation
I'll take a few pics for you guys it's 3
o'clock in the afternoon and we working
all day and I thought I'd introduce you
to the team that Lisa hi sizzling in
Swedish hey oh my god do man your agony
makes designer top this 110 rank he's
the boss wait hey guys I'm here being
managerial do you work with a lot of our
I do I do some data science wait I'm not
doing other stuff can you manage things
wow you guys are quite easy to myself
and this one's Lisa
Lucia she's Italian hi yes and they
would be like what Cassini periodontium
what an international office
[Music]
so we resolved the bugs from this
morning they've been they've gone
through code review and they'll soon be
in production and now it's time to look
at the pivotal tracker to see what
stories I should work on next
hey 340 we got about hour and a half
left in the day maybe a little bit more
and I'm gonna switch gears I've been
learning a bit of our we have a
hackathon coming up this weekend Lucia
and Lisa and I are gonna go and hack for
Sweden and so I need to get my art shops
up fortunately we have some our projects
in our repertoire as a company they
analyze our data and I am trying to
learn our so I can help work on those so
I'm going to run some tutorials and I'm
going to take a stab at a new
application we need for analyzing the
company's debt so it's 5:00 and
ordinarily I would stay at work a little
bit later but today I have a dance class
so I'm going to leave right after I
record this video today it was a pretty
good day i squashed two bugs that were
giving our support staff some trouble
and I finished a major refactor that is
going to kind of open up some paths for
us to do some more development in the
future I collaborated with my
counterpart our contractor in Poland he
helps a lot with the work that we do and
we could not do it without him on our
team it's as I mentioned it's it's me
and Lucci and Lisa and Henrik and that's
not quite enough programming for the
work that we have to do so we have these
other people the app team were around
even though they were announced and oh
um okay quick facts about working in
Sweden
my lovely UX designer and also Johan
who's our
honorary Tec member they're gonna have
babies soon and know now together
separate babies to babies and they'll
get 18 months of combined parental leave
that the both partners must take very
important and everybody makes about the
same amount of money like of course
there's fluctuations but like if you go
if you make too little the government
will just give you more and if you make
too much the government will like text
you a lot so everybody's kind of smushed
into this little bit working for a
product company is really great because
I'm really close to the the users of my
product support staff so we work really
really fast me like I got bugs in this
morning and I fixed them by the
afternoon and part of the reason that we
can do that is because our we're like
kind of free to make mistakes in a way
because the support staff will come and
say hey you broke this and we can fix it
within a few hours yeah gosh I could
talk so much but you see me all day so I
will just say goodbye from Sweden hej då
as it were and thanks for watching